welcome to heads up with stapes the show
where I chase down Team PokerStars pros
to find out more about their lives away
from the table then we play a little
heads up of our own today we're at the
childhood home of Team PokerStars Pro
Olivia burry now Liv and I have a little
history so things could be a teensy bit
awkward to kick things off I think it's
gonna be fine
there's only one way to find out it's
covering the doorbell I think she's
expecting us oh yeah hi Josie now before
we get started I just wanted to clear up
one thing but one thing to bed if you
will Thanks really that's those the
words you have to use that's exactly
what I'm talking about uh I do this gag
where I pretend like I'm really into Liv
she pretends like she's really creeped
out but really when the cameras are off
we're actually pretty close friends and
lift and you please just tell everyone
once and for all that we are
she's not gonna learn are you coming in
or not yes please insist on coming to my
house yes please thanks for playing
along with really appreciate what's that
hours are therapeutic discussing tell me
about all the animals that you have here
we'll start with this I want to say guy
but it's not a guy is it well yeah I can
tell by her natural aversion to me that
there is a female body this is mr.
austell and who was named mr. Osterman
because we were told it was a boy lizard
two turtles tortoises turtles live in
the sea a bunch of chickens I lose count
and dogs how many dogs who but there's
also like a revolving door of dogs that
come to stay such as the other two here
this is Bella
ah I've had since I was 12 she's
technically a pony she's wonderful
I actually had a until the age of 18 and
then when I went to university we had to
sell her but then I just want to
understand me my mom really - they
better stock up for sale please buy her
so she's back and she's an old lady now
she's like she's 19
so wait so you got to sell your horse
heartbroken you win at poker turnaround
by the worse back was it like the
warhorse was
let's talk a little bit about college or
did you guys call it university you have
a degree in astrophysics correct I used
to intern at NASA and I've brought a
really cool
astrophysics rocket ship blow your mind
alien bend the laws of time and space
excites experiment uh-huh
for me you to do and we can maybe even
turn into a little bit of a competition
are you down okay let's go do it bring
mr. Higgins bottom thing that explosions
have been very good to you I was down in
the South of France when me thought
volcano in Iceland or whatever it was
called went off basically I couldn't fly
home so I was stuck in the South of
France and someone was like well there's
an EPT going on over in Italy let's get
a train over so I was like all right
I'll go and place that light and then
bring to my seat how much money by the
way that's the money I think is the
number one EPT prize at the time ever so
good deal thanks a lot explosions thank
you mister volcano all right let's get
to work on those rockets oh man
building rockets is hard work she was
gonna get their face licked by a horse
just typical daytime fare free household
see guys out there the highest rocket
wins the losers got to get intimate with
Archie the horse 20 seconds and counting
t-minus 15 seconds guidance is internal
12 11
I can do this all day ouch oh my god oh
my god
I think I lost the nail and think I lost
a fingernail sequenced our
and it's stuck in the ground I got to
give you a bonus points for the dismount
look at this
that was that was like it a good good
out such as a white fireman I get my
face licked by a horse oh gee all right
well I'm gonna go meet the horse now see
you guys in a second okay so I lost the
rocket challenge this is Archie I'm
about to get to know him very well
Archie is really interested in this
Marmite that we've got the whole thing
what you're gonna have to do to get it
my friends really sticky so he's gonna
have to lick a lot to get it all hey
buddy come on I don't think I'd ever be
in a point Micra I'm begging a horse to
make out with me come on
all right live well the horse tasted me
I tasted the horse when it's teased in
my mouth I think that I have fulfilled
my obligation in this bed did that is be
paid that's all for this edition of
heads up with stapes don't forget to
subscribe to the show here on YouTube
follow us on Twitter I met Steve's shoes
at live underscore Barry and we'll see
you guys next time
heads up with Steve's someone kick me
god bless you
somebody give me a wet way next time on
heads up with stapes me a live talk life
on a balcony and we rock out